I wanted to ask you, because you just had the big, fun
gender announcement with your girlfriend, Jenna
and you guys met right before the pandemic
and you just announced that you're having a baby boy.
(audience applauding)
Congratulations.
Thank you so very much, thank you.
A mini Derulo.
Yeah, I could not be more excited, it's a boy.
You know, I think everything, you know
happens in like in the right time.
Like, I was just starting to like really
like get a baby fever, you know, I guess there's,
you know with age and you meet someone
that you really really connect with
and yeah you know,
it happened at just the right time for me.
That's interesting.
I haven't heard a man talk about baby fever.
We're usually the ones saddled with the like tick tock
and you know, men sometimes they're like, Oh God, don't,
you know the pressure.
And we're like, I know,
I got to keep the human race going, I know.
But it's interesting to hear a man say that,
and really wonderful.
How is your beautiful lady Jenna feeling?
So she's actually good.
It hasn't been a tough pregnancy at all.
So yeah, she's been really good.
The worst thing that happens, I guess is
he just kicks a lot, you know whenever he hears music,
he just starts dancing.
It's like, I want to do a TikTok on it
because I just pictured him in there just getting it.
(audience laughing)
Well with the worlds that you create Jason,
I feel like you can create a woman, a mini Derulo for sure,
if you wanted to.
All right next on the list.
You know, I've always gravitated towards people in my life
that I really looked up to,
and I know that you and Will Smith have this amazing
sort of like friendship,
and will you talk about that a little bit?
Yeah, for sure.
I totally agree with you,
I mean, being able to befriend someone that you look up to,
I think there's nothing like it.
When Will Smith says something,
you want to make sure that you're listening
'cause you gotta put that in your back pocket.
You know, he gives you life advice without even I knowing
that he's giving you life advice.
I'd be like, okay, cool.
I'm gonna take that,
I'm gonna put that right there.
Cool.
But it's incredible.
You know, I grew up watching him
and what he's been able to accomplish in different genres.
I mean, it's just really unbelievable.
So to be able to, you know
have a friend that I can learn from all the time,
you know there's just nothing like that.
It's so true,
and it really makes me think about your manager's story.
Is it true that you met him at a basketball game
when you were like 12 years old?
Yeah, yeah on a basketball court, he had these little,
he had this short shorts on and some high socks and
yeah I remember we needed one more player
and I was like, allright cool, I'll take the old guy,
come on.
And then he ended up being this crazy basketball player
and he started to mentor me as a basketball player,
because that previous year I didn't make my basketball team.
And I asked if he would help me with my basketball,
and he was just in the law school at the time
and he would just help me with my basketball,
and then that's what it was at that time.
And then how did your relationship transpire
because you guys are still together, right?
Yeah, for sure.
So basically, you know, he would just
whoop on me all the time in basketball,
and then one day I was like, you know what?
Basketball, not even my thing, I'm a singer.
And he's like, ah, come on, get out of here.
And he was like, all right, cool sing.
And then I sang something,
and he was like, wow, you really have something.
And then at that point he tried to act like he had
like all these connections
and he had a little something, something,
but we flew out to New York
to meet all of his connections,
door after door was shutting our face,
but we stuck to it and we learned together
and we continued to build what we have today,
which is 13 businesses and a lustrous empire.
I'm glad that he recognized your talent
with your voice and helped, you know stick with you
and help you pave the way for yourself,
and I'm really excited to talk about your latest single
"Lifestyles" with another phenomenal voice, Adam Levine.
I think the combination of the two of you
just sounds about as good as it gets.
But how did it come about?
You know what?
It was a pandemic collaboration.
When that happened remotely,
I finished the song and loved the song "Lifestyle"
and I sent it to my friend
who was also a writer on the song, Jay Cash.
And he frequently works with Adam as well.
And I was like, yo, send this to Adam,
and find out what he thinks about it.
Adam loved it and the rest is history.
I think that's again
I'm just going to say it one last time
what I really recognize in you is
these ideas are self-generated
and I really really respect that about you
and I thank you for putting all the good stuff
that you do out into the world, Jason Derulo.
(audience applauding)
Thank you, I appreciate that.
I really mean it, keep building
and we will all come,
check out Jason Derulo's single "Lifestyle"
featuring Adam Levine
and I can't wait to check in with you Jenna and mini Derulo
and see how you're all doing.
Okay well, I will talk to you soon, very soon.
Thank you so much.
I look forward to it.
(upbeat music)